ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Hi, I'm
Eric Schlaepfer.
Let's talk about the ADK 2012.
With me--
[APPLAUSE]
So just to finish the
introductions, over here is
Dmitry Grinberg, who worked
on the software.
Also over here is Travis
Geiselbrecht, who worked on
the software as well.
And, since I didn't mention
it before, I worked on the
hardware for the ADK 2012.
So first, let's talk about
accessories for Android.
There's a couple of
ways to connect
accessories to Android devices.
That includes USB
and Bluetooth.
So through USB, we can use
last year's Android Open
Accessory API.
And through Bluetooth, there's
a variety protocols for a
variety of purposes
that we can use.
And so a lot of the accessories
you can build
here, commercial purposes
include audio dock, exercise
equipment, medical devices,
that kind of thing.
But there's also a lot of
capability for hobby projects
as well, such as a robot
controller and all kinds of
wonderful things that people
can do with this.
So I'm sure you're dying
to see what the
ADK 2012 looks like.
So let's just go ahead
and take a look.
And here we have it.
We've attempted a little bit
more than we did last year.
All right, so what
is this thing?
This is an alarm clock.
You can take it out of the box
and plug it in and begin using
it as an Android-connected
alarm clock right away.
It's also an audio dock.
If you plug it into the USB
connection, you can transfer
audio from your phone to
the device and play it
back in real time.
You can do exactly the same
thing over Bluetooth as well.
And it also acts as an Android
accessory hacker platform.
It's totally extensible.
You can go in and edit
all the code.
You could even go in there with
a soldering iron and make
all kinds of changes to it.
So let's talk about some
of the features here.
We've loaded it down with a lot
of good stuff this year.
So we've got a light sensor in
the corner that can sense
ambient light levels, proximity,
and it has a built
in colorimeter, which we'll talk
about a little bit later.
There is a capacitive slider
control on the top for
adjusting the volume, adjusting
brightness, color,
all kinds of other functions.
And we've put in a bunch of
capacitive buttons as well.
In fact, almost the whole front
panel is capacitive.
There are also 64 RGB LEDs.
So all those 7-segment display
segments here, you can control
the color, set them to whatever
you want, display
patterns, all kinds
of cool things.
OK, now I'm sure you're
wondering what's inside.
So let's go ahead and
take it apart.
It's very easy.
You just squeeze the case.
There's not a single screw
in this entire design.
It's held together by magnets.
[APPLAUSE]
And here it is unfolded.
This is one of the first
devices that's actually
designed to be taken apart,
because we want you to take it
apart and hack on it.
So on the inside, let's
look at some of
the component pieces.
On the upper part, there's
a speaker.
And we use that to play back
alarm sounds, audio from
Bluetooth or USB.
And if it looks a little odd to
you, that's because it's a
transducer.
It connects to the back
panel of the device.
And it uses the entire back
surface as a speaker.
So you get big sound out
of a small device.
There's also a whole bunch of
sensors in there as well.
The ADK is aware of the
temperature, the humidity, the
barometric pressure, the
acceleration, and even the
local magnetic field.
Just imagine the potential
for that.
Also, on the side of the
device is an NFC Tag.
So when you first get your
device, you can take your
Nexus device and hover
it over the tag.
And it will send you to the app
store to download the app.
Let's talk about the
microcontroller.
I remember last year we had a
little AVR processor, a little
8-bit processor.
And it's a great little
processor.
But we decided to do it better
a little bit this year.
So this device has a 32-bit
ARM Cortex M3 processor.
We've connected a Bluetooth
device to it and an SD card.
And if some of the stuff looks
a little bit familiar, that's
because it's completely
programmable through the
Arduino IDE.
[APPLAUSE]
So if you don't want to use it
as an alarm clock, you can
actually take it apart
and pull the entire
board off of it.
And it's an Arduino,
except it's 32-bit.
So instead of writing code for
a processor running at 16
megahertz, you can take
that same code and
run it at 84 megahertz.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, let's talk about the
phone application.
So again, if you take your Nexus
device and you hover it
over the NFC Tag, you can
pick up the application.
You can plug in through USB,
and that will automatically
load the application for you.
Once you've launched it,
it'll give you a
little Connect menu.
And so you can use this to
connect though Bluetooth,
which is pretty straightforward.
So just search for devices
on Bluetooth.
And it'll show up
as the ADK 2012.
Click the Connect button, and it
will show a little code on
the front of the device.
So you can just click
OK here and pair up.
And once you're done, launch the
ADK application and click
Use Bluetooth.
And then pick it off the
menu and you're done.
That's it.
So one more step than you
would have to use for a
Bluetooth headset.
If you want to connect it
through USB, you do what you
would do last year.
Just plug it in and it works,
magically launches the
application.
And once you've done that,
you'll get the main screen
here, which has a number of
different functions here.
You can set the time.
You can set the alarm,
set the color.
You can choose some
display settings.
And you can lock the device as
well so you won't accidentally
brush up against the cap sense
and change your alarm.
Setting the time
is very simple.
You get a little time
picker like this.
And if you just click through
that, it sets it to your cell
phone network time.
So it's a very quick way
to update the time
on your alarm clock.
Alarms are similarly easy.
You can just come in, click on
the Menu, set the alarm time.
And you get to choose
the alarm sound.
There are a number
of sounds that we
pre-load onto the SD card.
And they're all in the
open-source Ogg format.
You can put all your own
songs on there as well.
And we've got a built-in
Ogg-Vorbis decoder.
All the source code is right
there for you look at.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, now let's talk about
setting the LED color.
And there's a couple
of ways to do it.
But my favorite way is something
that Dmitry here
will demonstrate for us.
So let me go ahead and switch
over to his screen.
And so we can see the clock that
he's been operating here.
OK, so Dmitry, go ahead and show
us the color picker mode.
I did tell you about
a colorimeter.
OK, so he's got--
DMITRY GRINBERG: So for example,
we can grab different
colored swatches and have the
device pick up their color.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And so, of
course, you can do this from
the application as well.
But just imagine the
possibilities.
You could take-- oh, for
example-- little colored jelly
beans and make a robot that
can recognize the
color and sort them.
I mean the possibilities
are endless with
this type of sensor.
You guys will love it.
OK, I'd like to pass things
off to Dmitry now to talk
about Bluetooth sound
and storage.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Thank
you, Eric.
So as Eric mentioned, we added
Bluetooth to this device, by
which we mean we added
real Bluetooth.
A lot of Arduino projects and
similar small embedded devices
use Bluetooth to Serial
converter chips, which just
give you a virtual
serial port.
That's all nice and great, but
it doesn't give you too much
flexibility.
So here in the ADK 2012, we have
a real Bluetooth chip.
It's a TI CC2564.
And it's connected over UART
to the main processor.
We have the on board antenna.
So everything you need to do
to play with Bluetooth is
right in the ADK.
We wrote our little Bluetooth
Stack for the ADK, mostly
because it's a very
simple one.
It runs on BareMetal.
And it's BSD licensed.
So you can just grab
it and use it.
You don't have to pay any
money in royalties.
You don't have to disclose
your code, nothing.
It is very simple.
It supports multiple concurrent
connections.
We implemented a service
discovery protocol server.
So you can advertise your
services so devices can
discover it.
And if you do want RFCOMM, which
is a Bluetooth serial,
we have that as well.
Here we have a few lines of
code just to show the
functionality we
have available.
You can set your device name,
get remote device names.
You can do device discovery.
You can make your device
connectable, discoverable,
everything else you'd expect
out of a Bluetooth Stack.
If you want to play with low
levels of Bluetooth, you can
use L2CAP Protocol, which
we give you access to.
You can create L2CAP sockets.
You can receive connections
on them.
It's all extremely
simple to do.
Whenever data arrives, a call
back gets called and you can
process it.
And you can send data back with
a simple function call.
The data is sent
asynchronously.
So, in fact, you don't have
to keep it around.
You don't have to worry.
It'll get sent whenever
it's needed to.
You just call one function.
And this is something you'd use,
for example, to implement
Bluetooth HID, if you
want to have the ADK
pretend to be a keyboard.
But, of course, the way
Bluetooth discovers what
service your device
has is SDP.
It allows devices to query and
receive responses about what
services your device supports.
We have a fully working SDP
server in our device that
supports the entire SDP spec.
So you can discover
services on here.
The API is, once again,
extremely simple.
You can just add and remove
descriptors using two functions.
And as soon as you add a
descriptor, it begins being
advertised.
And, of course, the ADK source
code includes examples of
this, because that is how the
phone application communicates
with the ADK.
For virtual serial ports, of
course, we have RFCOMM, which
acts to you just like
a serial port.
You'll get a call back
when data arrives.
You can call a function
to send data.
And, once again, the example
is in the ADK.
And we support multiple
connections.
And it's actually quite fast.
So I've tried making a small
ADK application that just
pipes data back to you.
And we got one megabit full
duplex throughput through this
chip and through the entire
ADK code stack.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So kind of what
this means for you guys
is that not only is this
protocol stack completely
exposed to all of you-- you guys
can look through all the
lower layers, all the
upper layers--
but RFCOMM is a great way
to get started with it.
So if all of these acronyms
don't really make a whole lot
of sense to you, if that's
something you don't want to
dig into, then you can just look
at this example we have
on this slide right here.
And using RFCOMM, which is the
simplest serial protocol, is
literally that simple.
So it's very scalable.
DMITRY GRINBERG: And we've tried
this with multiple OSes,
not just Android.
It works with Linux and
a few other OSes
we've tried as well.
And the other thing we
added to the ADK this
year is A2DP support.
So the ADK is actually a fully
working Bluetooth speaker.
We have an SBC decoder
in here.
It supports mono, all three
stereo versions, everything
you'd need out of a
Bluetooth device.
And we've also tested it with
multiple OSes, including
Android and Linux.
And it does work.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Would you like
to demonstrate that now?
DMITRY GRINBERG: I don't
know if I have any--
I guess I can play some
alarms, sure.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Let's
give it a shot.
I'm not sure what the 2.4
gigahertz spectrum looks like
in here, but we'll
see what happens.
DMITRY GRINBERG: We'll
find out soon enough.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So let's
consider this a stress test of
the Bluetooth Stack.
So if all these people with
Bluetooth-connected phones out
here, and I can imagine 2.4
gigahertz right now, let's
take a look and see
if this will--
well--
DMITRY GRINBERG: I want to see
what ring tone I can grab.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: I hope you've
already paired with it,
because you're going to get a
very long list of devices.
DMITRY GRINBERG: I
imagine so, yes.
[FAINT BEEP]
There, well, I guess
it's not very loud.
But you can hear it.
[RINGING]
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And
it's ringing.
Your alarm clock is ringing.
[PIANO MUSIC]
DMITRY GRINBERG: It's not
playing out of my phone.
You heard it out of the ADK.
[APPLAUSE]
And on the phone side,
the Bluetooth
is very, very simple.
For example, here is an
RFCOMM sample for you.
And it's very easy to
make this work.
This is literally the code you
need to communicate with the
ADK in the simplest form.
You create a connection.
And, as you see, we do a
discovery using this UUID.
This is just a UUID you
create yourself.
And as long as it matches on the
ADK side and your Android
side, the connection
will be made.
And then you get an input stream
and an output stream.
So in Java, you just send
bytes and receive bytes.
There's no further
complications
for you to deal with.
One of the other additions
this year to the ADK, as
you've just seen, is sound.
And we've made it really,
really easy for
everyone to use this.
So the audio data is piped to
the audio digital analog
converter using DMA.
So your code doesn't have
to conform to any timing
requirements or really do
anything complicated.
It just works.
The API is very simple,
as you can see.
You can just enqueue
an audio buffer.
And that buffer gets played
whenever the audio hardware
gets to it.
And the code will block until
it's time to do that.
Or you can use instead
a [? TryAddBuffer ?]
buffer.
And that way you can know if
the current audio buffer is
already full.
The thing you see there with
a source is one of the
interesting things about ADK.
We didn't want to put a full
audio mixer in it, not because
we couldn't.
But we just didn't think
it was appropriate.
So instead, there is some code
in here to do audio lock out.
So there's a fixed priority
of services.
For example, Alarm overrides
anything else.
So if you try to play a file
while the alarm is going on,
alarm wins and your
data gets dropped.
And, of course, this is all
code you can modify.
So if you want to add your
own audio mixer,
you're free to do so.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: What this means
for the people that are
going to use it as an alarm
clock before starting to hack
on it is that if you set up, and
you've got music playing
on it, and then the alarm goes
off, the alarm will interrupt
the music just like you
would expect it to.
DMITRY GRINBERG: And we went
a little further than that,
because no one likes
uncompressed audio.
So as Eric previously mentioned,
we did have an Ogg
decoder in here now.
So the alarms that are in the
device are Ogg format.
And the API for that is
extremely simple.
The simplest way is just
to call Play Ogg
and give it a path.
That's all you have to do.
The audio will just
start playing.
Also you can do it in the
background if you wanted to.
And we also have a global
volume control.
For storage, we have a MicroSD
slot on the device.
And all the devices have MicroSD
in them already.
And the API is very simple,
as you would expect.
There's an SD driver in place
and a FAT16, 32, and 12
driver built in.
It's got all the functions
you'd expect.
You can open files, close files,
read them, write them,
you can create directories.
A few things that most embedded
file system drivers
don't have, you can also format
a card or move files.
And this is all, once again,
code you get, code you can
modify, reuse, whatever
you want.
Now I want to hand it over to
Travis to talk about some of
the USB things.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT:
Thank you, Dmitry.
So the ADK also has USB,
as it did last
year and similar today.
Dmitry is going to show us the
two ports on the back.
That's the inside of it.
There are two USB ports
on this device.
The first one is used
for programming.
It looks like a standard
FTDI bay serial port.
That's the one you use
for debugging and--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: I think you're
on the wrong side.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Yeah--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: There you go.
DMITRY GRINBERG: This
thing's upside down.
It's really hard.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yeah.
See, so there's two
ports here.
They're both micro USB.
The other one was one that's
really interesting.
That's a USB host port.
So on ADK 1.0, there was a--
same thing, USB host.
But it was implemented as an
external chip that actually
handled most of it.
For this time around, we
actually pulled the host stack
into the ARM processor.
In the case in this particular
ARM, it had on-the-go USB
controller.
So we put it in host mode and
implemented the stack.
So the full source
is available.
It's running on the ARM.
It does everything that we'll
talk about here in a minute.
If you've never used an Android
accessory protocol, it
actually shows up in an
inverted way that
you normally expect.
The device implements host,
the accessory device.
And the phone or tablet or
round sphere of something
shows up as an actual
device to the ADK.
And, really, the nitty gritty
details is there's a little
handshake at the beginning.
And then it ends up exporting
to bulk endpoints.
And it's just data in and out.
It's very similar to what
we did last year.
And then it's up to you
the format whatever
protocol you want.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So Travis,
you did mention a sphere.
And what you're referring to
is the Nexus Q demo that's
happening right now on the third
floor with that giant
ball and the robot arm
and all of that.
That's all being done through
an ADK 2.0 from a Nexus Q
using the Android Open
Accessory protocol.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yes.
So actually, if you look
there, there's a ball--
[APPLAUSE]
And that's running an Arduino
sketch that was written a
couple weeks ago.
You've actually already
seen one.
And most people hadn't
recognized that it was
actually an ADK.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: It was
at that point I really
appreciated the power and
simplicity of Arduino, because
we were down to the wire.
And I had to get this
thing done.
And so, I just whipped
up a quick sketch.
And it worked great, as you can
see if you go up to the
third floor.
Go ahead.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Oh,
and so also, here's
the list of the API.
It's a very simple API
on the device side.
For the accessory protocol,
most of the actual API is
setting the different strings,
which is what your device
would show up to.
There's a list of strings that
you can match against, where
you can name yourself, you know,
in this case, ADK 2012
or My Cool Widget.
And that's exactly how the app
on Android side will know
which app to connect to or what
the protocol version is.
So most of the API is just for
setting those strings.
And at the very bottom, you
basically have three calls,
are you connected, send
data, receive data.
There's not much to it.
It doesn't format it.
It's just a string of bytes.
It's up to you to define
whatever protocol you want.
In our case, we actually
developed about a 10 or 15 op
code, send and receive protocol
to support all the
sensors and what not on that.
And we used the same protocol
to punch over
Bluetooth as well.
So it's quite straightforward.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So you can look
at the sketch that we'll
provide with the full source
code and see that as an
example of sort of a medium
complexity example of
transferring data back
and forth over USB.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Right.
And this is actually,
essentially,
the minimum set up.
You'll see at the top, we
initialized the ADK and set
the accessory strings for
whatever your device
will show up as.
And then in the main loop, you
basically are just testing,
are you connected,
are you not?
Send data, process
it, send it back.
There's not much to it.
It's a little bit
more complexity
on the Android side.
But this, of course, is not any
different from last year.
This accessory protocol's been
in Android since Gingerbread.
But, for the most part, you set
up the connection, and,
you do a little bit more error
checking than on the slide,
but probably about twice
as much code
in the final solution.
But then, at the bottom, you end
up with two input streams.
Input, output stream, you punch
protocol over that.
And that's pretty much
it, not a lot to it.
There is a little bit of string
matching that you do
inside the app to decide which
device to connect to.
And, of course, Android lets you
register a particular app
to start automatically
when it sees
this particular accessory.
And that's all handled inside
the manifest of the app.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So if you
notice that the last two lines
look familiar, you're right,
because we use the very same
stream mechanism
for Bluetooth.
In fact, in our application,
what we've done is we've
abstracted it and wrapped them
in two different classes that
both inherit from a
master class that
has two stream objects.
And that allows our ADK
application to use either USB
or Bluetooth with exactly
the same code.
And you, of course, can
use that code in your
own projects as well.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: And there's
one more feature that
we added for this one.
And this is new since
last year.
Part of a feature that was added
in Jellybean is there is
a generic USB audio mechanism.
And it's an extension of
the accessory protocol.
And, basically, it--
this is well, of course,
documented
on the Android side.
There's actually no API
involved, which is why there's
no code to actually show you.
But basically, it's a little
handshake that happens when
the device goes into
accessory mode.
And then the phone or tablet or
round spherical thing turns
into a USB audio device,
basically looks like a
microphone more or
less to this.
It's full 16-bit, 44.1, PCM
data, no compression or
anything like that.
And what we're using this device
for is essentially an
example code.
Here is an example of how you
would go implement it.
You might not even use
this exact code.
But, you know, if you're
designing something based on a
PIC or an AVR or something more
exotic, you could also
use the same thing.
This is, of course,
well-documented.
So this acts like an
example to it.
And same thing with--
like I said, this is in
Jellybean and above.
All devices have it.
If it's got Jellybean, it
supports this protocol.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So what this
means for all of you is that
you can take your Jellybean
Nexus that you got here, plug
it into your ADK, and without
any menus or configuration or
anything, you can immediately
begin playing
audio through it.
[APPLAUSE]
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yeah,
you'll see a little pop up
that says, connected
as an audio device.
And then that's it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And
then it just works.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yep.
All right.
So, I'm going to hand it back
over to Eric, who's going to
go through the rest of the fun
gadgets you can do with it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: The pretty
lights, let's talk about
blinking lights.
There are 64 RGB LEDs on this
guy, six 7-segment digits, two
colons that you can control
separately, eight icon
indicators, and 12 party
mode lights.
I can't wait to see what
you guys do with those.
That'll be fun.
Actually, I think Dmitry might
have done a little
bit of a demo here.
So let's go and switch over to
that camera and take a look.
So, he's actually been busy
coding up a bunch
of different demos.
[APPLAUSE]
Dmitry, that looks
really good.
He's been going through so many
different visualization
algorithms over the last
couple of days.
I'd just look over his desk
and, oh, look at that.
There's another neat
pattern, very cool.
So I'd love to see what you
guys come up with as well.
Please go and record videos.
Put them up on YouTube.
I look forward to seeing
all of that.
So the API to control those LEDs
is very straightforward.
Since we handle all the LED
muxing and the LED controller
in the background through an
interrupt-based system,
there's really not a whole
lot you have to do.
Just ledWrite, put in the index
of the LED and the red,
green, and blue values,
and then it just sort
of magically happens.
And you don't have to worry
about anything.
If you want to get more
complicated, you could use the
ledDrawLetter function and put
it in essentially ASCII value,
and that will show up on the
digit that you've selected.
Now, granted, it's a
7-segment display.
So certain letters, like M and
N and some of those other
tricky ones, we can't display.
But we do our best.
So, play with it and
see what you think.
And those are the LEDs.
Let's talk about the capacitive
touch sensors.
They are actually 12 buttons,
one each for the up and down
on each segment.
And what that allows you to do
is, if you're in clock mode,
you can set the clock just by
touching the top or the bottom
of each digit.
Dmitry, did want to
demonstrate that?
DMITRY GRINBERG: Why not?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK, let's
switch to the camera and take
a look here.
It's a little hard to
talk about it but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DMITRY GRINBERG: I can try
setting that time.
There's 11:00, 10:00.
You can also just
do it quicker.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And let me
tell you, this is great
because I have one of those
old alarm clocks at home,
where it's got the hour button
and the minute button.
And then you're hitting
the button.
And you're like, OK, I'm getting
there, getting there,
get-- oh, I went too far.
Now you get to go all the
way back around again.
DMITRY GRINBERG: It also works
for setting the alarm and
enabling and disabling it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Very nice.
So there's a lot you can
do with those buttons.
[APPLAUSE]
We've also got a slider
control on
the top of the device.
And so, we use that as
a volume control.
And depending on the mode that
you're in, it can also adjust
the color of the LEDs as well.
So, since we've got the demo
screen up, you might want to
go to Color.
And we can take a
look at that.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Sure.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And so that
just runs through all these
different colors, very pretty.
Excellent.
Thanks, Dmitry.
OK, let's talk about sensors.
You got a little bit of a
preview of some of those
sensors when I was talking
about it earlier.
There's a thermometer hygrometer
device that will
give you the temperature as well
as the relative humidity
in percent.
I think everybody that I showed
it to came by and had
to breathe on it to see if their
breath would increase
the humidity, which it did.
And, yes, I was able to
saturate the sensor.
There's also a barometer
that's in the device.
It's incredibly sensitive.
In fact, it's so sensitive to
pressure that if I take an ADK
and I hold it up here, and then
I drop it down here, it
can tell the difference
in pressure.
We've also got-- thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We've also got an accelerometer
magnetometer.
So let's switch to
the camera again.
And so, Dmitry's going to show
us what that looks like on the
real time display.
DMITRY GRINBERG: So this
is the device in
accelerometer mode.
So, blues are negative,
reds are positive.
So I can rotate it and see
the accelerations change.
And we can do the same for
a magnetometer as well.
So I can attempt to find some
direction of north here if I
knew how to interpret
this data.
But it does show some
random value.
So as far as looking cool
goes, it works.
[APPLAUSE]
And the other sensors
are here as well.
So there's the temperature,
26.3 Celsius.
Humidity, I'm not going to make
Eric breathe on this.
We have the current pressure,
proximity, and you already saw
the color matching mode.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER:
Thanks, Dmitry.
[APPLAUSE]
It's funny, when we were doing
some rehearsals for the demos,
we were running this
off of a battery.
And he picked this up, and he
literally threw it at me.
But it was in accelerometer
mode.
And all the numbers went to zero
because it's essentially
in free fall.
And so, of course, I was a
little scared because here's
this thing flying
through the air.
But then I'm looking
at the LEDs.
Hey, they're all zero.
Physics works.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Unfortunately
for you, he did not get hit.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK,
so the API that's
involved is very simple.
And it actually handles all the
calibration calculations,
of which there are many.
Especially that barometer,
there's a lot of number
crunching that we had to
do to get real numbers.
But the good news for you
guys is that all that
code has been done.
It's all written.
And the API is very simple.
You just make a function
call here to,
for example, baroRead.
And you just pass in pressure
and temperature, and it will
go in and take those pointers
and put numbers in them.
And now you've got the pressure
and the temperature.
It's very simple.
All right, Dmitry's going to
talk about the sample code for
the clock sketch
in the Arduino.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Thank you.
So the code of everything that
I'm demonstrating here, this
is all built in.
We're giving this code
to you of course.
And there's a few interesting
things to look into that.
And there's absolutely no way I
can go through all of it or
even a large piece of it.
The interesting thing to mention
here, if you've ever
used Arduino before, is a lot
of this stuff happens in the
background.
Some of it's interrupt driven.
Some of it is not.
So we actually have a small
cooperative multitasking
system behind the scenes to let
everything happen behind
scenes, like Bluetooth
and USB.
So, once in a while, you have
to call ADK event process,
which just allows the ADK
to process all of
its background work.
And you can do that whenever
you're in a busy loop or in
some other such place.
And if you don't do that,
bad things will happen.
So please do.
And--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So, just
to go back to that, the
multitasking thing sounds
complicated.
Like, do I really have
to worry about that?
Or is it as simple as making
that function call every once
in a while?
DMITRY GRINBERG: So, if you
don't want to play around with
multitasking, you just make
that function call and
everything works.
If you want to, you can play
around with the multitasking.
And it's actually very simple.
There's two functions, really,
if you care about.
One to launch a thread
and one to yield.
And the thread dies
just whenever you
return from that function.
So if you want to use
it, go ahead.
It is in the code.
And the other example here is
how we display the time.
And it is just these
few lines.
I skipped the minutes
and seconds.
But you just get the RTC
and display them.
The next line you see there is
how the alarm sounds are
played for the alarm.
And, also, we have an
alarm preview that
does that as well.
So if I go to the alarm mode--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I don't think we have a
microphone on anymore.
But it does do that using
the Ogg play background.
As soon as I let go,
it gets canceled.
And also, we have the Process
USB accessory function, which
handles the USB messages
that arrive.
That gets called in the main
loop, unlike the USB code,
which gets called
from the USB--
or, sorry, Bluetooth
code, which gets
called from the callback.
This is actually
that callback.
And the data arrives.
And we pass it to
adkProcessCommand, which just
processes the command received
and sends back a response.
That function's actually
in common between
Bluetooth and USB.
So protocol is the same.
So when you're writing your
Android application, you
shouldn't need to know
or care how you're
connected to the ADK.
Everything should work
exactly the same.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Excellent.
[APPLAUSE]
DMITRY GRINBERG: We were really
hoping you guys have a
lot of questions.
So let's have it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So where there
are microphones in the
middle of the room here-- so if
you have a question, please
come up and ask it.
And we'll do our
best to answer.
AUDIENCE: Shut up and
take my money.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: No, it's a really
impressive piece of [? kit. ?]
I actually had a couple
questions about the--
I'm a big Arduino fan.
What are you guys running
in the Arduino?
Like, what Arduino
are you running?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: What Arduino
are we running?
AUDIENCE: With respect to,
you know, its amount of
capability.
Is it a--
let's take it apart.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK, so I think
what you're asking is,
this is a 32-bit device.
And it's clearly running
under the Arduino IDE.
So what Arduino is
it based on?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: And the answer
is actually that it's
kind of its own thing.
It's similar in certain ways
to the Arduino Due.
But it's definitely not
the same thing.
It's kind of its own animal.
But it still retains the
ease of use that
you get with Arduino.
And so, if you go to our website
and you download all
of that stuff, you can just
select Google ADK 2.0 and then
just start running
sketches on it.
AUDIENCE: So you have your own
built like the [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC SCHLAEPFER:
Right, exactly.
Now, you won't necessarily be
able to run all that ADK 2.0
code on an Arduino Due when
it hits the market, right?
So they are different devices.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: We did work
with Arduino for this.
Just the timing worked out to
where this comes out a little
bit before they have their
ARM-based things.
I don't know the
timing on that.
But when they do, these ought
to be pretty close.
So this is kind of a preview
release of Arduino for ARM.
AUDIENCE: It's really,
really impressive.
This segment [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: I mean,
it's very close.
So this won't be--
this is not some strange fork.
It's based very, very
closely [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DMITRY GRINBERG: We also do have
a build without Arduino,
just a basic make file build
that we'll be providing as
well for those who don't
want to use the
Arduino ID for some reason.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thank you very much, guys.
You crushed it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: All right,
next question.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Let's go with
the person in the front--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Up
front, please.
DMITRY GRINBERG: --alternate.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So last year's ADK was really
more of like a prototype
board, which other manufacturers
would then
create their own variations,
maybe at differing cost, price
points, or whatever.
But this year's ADK seems to be
more of a finished product.
I was wondering, what is the
plan for supporting this
outside of your product
going forward?
Are other manufacturers
expected to
produce a final good?
Or are they producing boards,
which then we then build upon?
And the second part the question
is, what, if any, of
your convenience code can be
shared for ADK 2012 that's not
manufactured by Google?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK, so we've
got a two-part question here.
The first part, the PC board
files-- and that includes the
schematics and the layouts
and all of that--
all that's done in EAGLE.
And that's completely
open source.
So anybody else is free to make
a copy of that and begin
manufacturing it.
For the second part of the
question, I think Dmitry here
can answer that.
DMITRY GRINBERG: The source
code is also free.
You're free to use it.
The licensing is
very friendly.
I don't think we have any code
that makes you pay for it.
We don't have any code
that you have to open
your source code for.
So you can grab our code, use
it however you please.
I believe the licenses
are all in there.
And the code is going to be
made available, I believe,
right after this talk.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Right.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yeah,
right about now.
DMITRY GRINBERG: So if you want
to grab the Bluetooth
stack, or you want to grab
Travis' USB host code, or you
want to grab some of the sensor
calibration code, you
just grab it and use
it by yourself.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So, for
example, what specific license
do you use for the BSD stack--
or the BTstack?
DMITRY GRINBERG: The BTstack, I
think, is actually licensed
Apache or BSD or something
of the sort.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Excellent.
So it's usable for anyone.
Next question, please--
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER:
--in the back.
You're welcome.
Anyone in the back?
Nobody in the back.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Next
person up front.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if you
could talk about the
hackability of the Nexus Q and
how you guys came up with that
demo and how you would write
an application for just a
simple Arduino--
not an ADK--
interfacing with the Nexus Q.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So the
important thing to recognize
is that the Nexus Q
runs full Android.
And so, it's perfectly capable
of running Android
applications.
And it also has the Android Open
Accessory protocol in it.
And so we essentially worked
with it just like we would
work with a phone.
DMITRY GRINBERG: The main point
being there's absolutely
nothing special being
done for it.
You don't have to do anything.
It just works.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for a great
presentation.
I'm more of a software guy
than electronic guy.
So maybe my question could
be very silly.
But I heard that there is a
problem with USB host that
it's also charging the phone.
So its problem that you
shouldn't charge the accessory
from battery because you'll run
out fast of the battery.
So is it true?
And if yes, is it a better way
to make accessories that work
only with phone and are not
connected to electricity?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Sure.
I'll take this question,
Travis.
So it's kind of a known issue
with the way that USB
accessories work.
And, essentially, what happens
is the phone becomes a
peripheral.
And the accessory becomes
the host.
And because of that
relationship, the way that USB
works, the accessory, then, has
to provide power to the
host, which is a
little strange.
And the reason has to do with
sort of the lack of adoption
of USB On-The-Go, which I think
is rather unfortunate.
But it's the world that we
live in, and we have
to deal with it.
At the same time, though, a
redemptive factor is that
Bluetooth is getting more and
more popular, especially for
accessories.
And so, I think that it's OK
that USB has its limitations
because I want people to focus
on developing Bluetooth
accessories.
Wireless really is the future.
And that's where we need to be
focusing our new development.
And it's more fun, too.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, the
USB audio API that was just
announced in [INAUDIBLE], it
didn't really have any
documentation for it.
And I just wanted to ask if
you know whether it only
allows Google Play to stream
music out that.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT:
Oh no, not at all.
All audio on the phone goes
through it at that point.
It basically turns it into a--
AUDIENCE: OK.
So any app.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Yeah, any
app, everything that plays
sound goes through it.
And it--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So,
notifications, alarms, you
could even use it like a
speaker phone, right?
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Mm-hm.
And this is fully documented
on Android's side under the
accessory protocol--
I don't know if it's under
Jellybean docs or somewhere
along those lines, but--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: It should
be on there right now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
There is documentation up
on the website now.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: There's
actually no API for it because
it either works or it doesn't.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Any output you
do on audio goes through
the device as long as
it's plugged in.
AUDIENCE: And isochronous mode,
is that going to be
supported, you think?
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Isochronous mode
for high sample rate USB
accessories.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: At the
moment, I believe it is fixed
at 44.1 16 bit--
DMITRY GRINBERG: I think he's
asking about the packet types
being used on USB.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: Oh, ISO.
Sorry, sorry.
Yes, it's all isochronous.
It looks like a standard
USB audio, nothing
particularly funny.
But it does use isochronous
transfers.
In this particular case, at 44.1
16 bit, I think it's 192
bytes every frame.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious--
I'm not sure if I heard
correctly-- its Cortex, which
actual package?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Well, you
can certainly open it
up and take a look.
We're using the SAM3X processor
from Atmel.
AUDIENCE:: OK, cool.
And is everything pinned out?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Most things
are pinned out.
There's a couple of things that
aren't because, well, we
ran out of Arduino pins.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thank you.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Most--
but Eric spent a lot of time
making sure all the more
interesting things are
available for you.
So the things missing might
be just some bare GPIOs.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: That's
a good point.
And we really didn't have time
to mention it in the actual
presentation.
But when I went through and
planned out which pins went
out to which Arduino pins, I was
very careful to make sure
that all the interesting pins
that have hardware accelerated
functions actually go
out to Arduino pins.
So, for example, the SAM3X
actually can support an
external Ethernet FI.
And so, I made sure that all
those connections made it out
to Arduino pins.
So that means that somebody--
maybe even one of you-- could
make an Ethernet shield for
this device very easily.
AUDIENCE: And could we actually
flash our own
firmware too?
DMITRY GRINBERG:
Oh, of course.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: 100%
DMITRY GRINBERG: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So all the code for
this is out too [INAUDIBLE]
DMITRY GRINBERG: The
code is out.
The tools are out.
You can grab one and flash
it five minutes from now.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: It's
very simple actually.
One of the two ports
acts like a serial
port, the debug board.
And the Atmel ROM has
a loader mode.
It's well understood.
There's an open source tool
called BOSSA out there that
people use to update
these things.
And, yeah, absolutely, you're
flashing it from
zero right on up.
DMITRY GRINBERG: One addition
to that is we have our own
tool called the ADK 2.0 Tool,
which is just used
to erase the chip.
It just so happens that whenever
you plug this into
certain platforms that aren't
Linux, the device gets erased
all by itself because those
platforms insist on twiddling
the control lines in
the serial port.
So we have an extra little
microcontroller on the board
to avoid such unpleasantries.
So there is a tool called the
ADK 2.0 Tool, which we're
releasing in source and binary,
which you use then to
erase the device.
Once it's erased, the Atmel
bootloader takes over and you
can load your own firmware.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: It's actually
kind of a fun hack because
we're using the control lines.
And one of them becomes
a clock line.
The other one becomes
a data line.
And we actually clock a little
magic number into this tiny
little microprocessor.
And when it sees the
right code, then it
tweaks the erase pin.
And so you don't have to
interact with any physical
buttons to erase the
code at all.
Question?
AUDIENCE: My question
is about the NFC.
According to the document at the
developer site, using by
NFC, lock the device and unlock
the device [INAUDIBLE].
So my question is,
[? from your ?]
[? call ?]
can [? interrupt ?] with some
other devices through NFC or
DEP or some protocol?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK.
So the question has
to do with NFC.
And we have an NFC Tag
on the device.
And that's a passive tag.
And what it does is it sends
your phone to Google Play to
download the application.
We didn't lock it.
So it's in read/write mode,
which means you could peel it
off and put something else
on it if you want to.
The ADK itself doesn't really
support NFC at this point.
Although if you're interested,
you may be able to put
together a shield for us,
which would be awesome.
AUDIENCE: Have you guys explored
the possibility of
building a REST API to allow,
maybe, HTML, JavaScript
interaction?
I know with Raspberry Pi
I've explored that.
And it's really accelerated
prototyping.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Well, I mean,
this would make a little more
sense if we had a
network-connected device.
But we don't actually have
Wi-Fi on this device.
So maybe once we have Wi-Fi--
AUDIENCE: I actually meant on
the Android side of it.
So the actual server, REST,
API would reside on the
Android device.
And you could actually
have HTML5 apps.
They would interact.
DMITRY GRINBERG: I don't
think any of us have
thought about it.
But you can implement it.
I mean, the API to talk to this
is available, so there's
no reason you can't do it.
And then we can come and ask
you questions about it.
[LAUGHTER]
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: No, but
I'll bring that up as
something to talk to the--
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: I like
that idea though.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT: --accessory
developers though,
yeah, absolutely.
DMITRY GRINBERG: That could
be pretty interesting.
AUDIENCE: Can you speak a little
bit about battery life
and power consumption?
Of course, it depends
what it's running.
But, for instance, are there
low power modes?
And what are some figures for
battery life and power
consumption?
DMITRY GRINBERG: So, I don't
think we ever meant this to be
a battery-powered device.
There's a hole in back for all
the cables, including a power.
But I have run this
off battery.
And it runs.
I don't think we've actually
measured the battery
consumption.
I don't think it was ever meant
to be such a thing.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So, just to
talk about the electrical
aspect of that, you could
certainly take the base shield
and power that from a battery.
The SAM3X device actually
includes a fairly complicated
power management device that
will allow you to go in and
throttle the clock down.
So it's actually got a
full-blown clock tree.
And there's a lot of stuff
going on in there.
Most of that complexity
is available if you
want to hack on it.
But for people that just want to
get it working as an alarm
clock or play with Arduino,
it's all hidden.
So you don't have to worry about
it if you don't want to.
But if you do you want to worry
about power consumption,
there are definitely ways to
go in there and tweak that.
Now, obviously, if you're
running all 64 RGB LEDs and
got some bass thumping on this
thing, it's really not going
to last that long.
DMITRY GRINBERG: It does
work on battery though.
So I can actually show that.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Oh,
look at that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DMITRY GRINBERG:
You can do it.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So you guys mentioned
just a minute ago
that you could have one of these
flashed in five minutes.
So I'm just kind of curious.
I came in a little late.
So maybe you said it.
But what's the availability
on these devices?
And how can we get our
hands on them?
DMITRY GRINBERG: I believe all
you already will get your
hands on it.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: That's actually
a really good segue.
Since we're nearing the end of
the session, everybody in this
room is going to get
their own ADK.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Just a question
out of curiosity.
You said you checked the
Bluetooth connection with
various other platforms.
Does that include
a major rivaling
mobile operating system?
DMITRY GRINBERG: I don't
have a Windows Phone.
So I can't tell you that.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
DMITRY GRINBERG: However, it
does work with another rival
operating system.
I actually use mine at home to
play music off of my iPhone.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Is that the one
from a certain Cupertino
fruit company?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Are you providing
any reference
schematics or PCV docs?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: Absolutely.
So, they're all being
posted on the
website in EAGLE format.
So you can pull them up in the
free version of EAGLE and
start hacking away.
AUDIENCE: What's the current
and future status of
availability of shields
for this?
So, I mean, it's a fairly
standard pin
out, it looks like.
But I'm just wondering if you
can sort of talk about what's
out there that can be already
plugged into this today.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: So the device
is compatible with any Arduino
Version 3.0 shield and
that's because
it's a 3.3-volt device.
And so any shield that wants to
use that needs to have its
own on-board level shifters.
And so the V3.0 Arduino shield
format includes that inner
specification.
So there's a reference pin
that you use to set the
reference voltage
and communicate
that onto the shield.
And so if you have a V3.0
shield, you plug it in, it
should just work.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How much memory
do we have on
the outer unit itself?
DMITRY GRINBERG: So there's
a few memories here.
So let me go over them.
The SD card the units
come with, I
believe, is four gigabytes.
The device itself has 512
megabytes of flash for storing
code and constant data.
TRAVIS GEISELBRECHT:
Kilobytes.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Oh, I'm
sorry, 512 kilobytes.
[LAUGHTER]
Wishful thinking, I must say.
And the device itself has 100
kilobytes of RAM as well.
There's 96 contiguous
kilobytes for--
and there's also four more in
the NAND controller, which
we're not using.
So you can use those as well.
So it's about 100 kilobytes
of RAM total.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, could you also
elaborate on availability for
things like educational
discounts or just general
consumer buying the device in
the future, what the plans are
going forward?
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: At this point,
it's a giveaway for
Google I/O. There may be
some future plans.
All I can say is, stay tuned.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK, great.
Any more questions?
DMITRY GRINBERG: I think there's
a person raising their
hand right there.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: I don't
see any hands.
DMITRY GRINBERG: Must have
been stretching.
ERIC SCHLAEPFER: OK.
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And before you guys leave the
room, please note that for the
giveaway there are going
to be people by the
doors holding cards.
Be sure to grab a card because
that is your ticket for your
free ADK that you can get
at the stuff booth
on the first floor.
Thank you for coming.